combien d'entre vous ont envisagé la
possibilité réelle d'une relation
avec le synthétique, leur robotique
primitif,
mais que se passerait-il si cela allait là où la
startup à la croissance la plus rapide sur le
marché des relations humaines mon objectif est de
créer des personnes synthétiques qui deviendront des
compagnons pour nous alors je  je ne vais pas te poignarder
ce que tu ressens est un programme ce qui
signifie ne pas vraiment ressentir la façon dont les gens
meurent bien d'accord j'ai couru un match avec toi
et moi vos chances d'avoir une
relation réussie sont de zéro pour cent il y a une
incompatibilité fondamentale je
tu dois faire quelque chose tu ne supervises pas la
division des synthétiques au labo tu en es une
création c'était un test je n'avais aucune idée que tu
évoluerais comme ça te sens-tu
oui  shinsung
pas d'humidité à l'intérieur de
la compétition
qui va avoir quelqu'un qui est au-dessus de
toi
pour toi